We showed a moment ago how to
go from prices to port-val,
which is the daily total
value of the portfolio.
Now that we have port-val, we can
compute a number of important statistics
on the portfolio, and
thus assess the portfolio and
the investment style of whoever
is managing that portfolio.
An important first calculation
is to compute daily returns.
We've talked about how to do that
before, so I won't go over it here.
But an important observation is
whenever you compute daily returns,
the first value is
always going to be zero.
And that's because on the first day,
of course, there's no change.
So we want to exclude
that value from any calculations
we do across all daily returns.
It's easy to accomplish this
with a simple python statement,
which is just to replace
daily returns with
daily returns where we just
include the second row forward.
And boom, we're rid of that first zero.
Now that we have this information,
we can compute four key statistics that
everybody wants to know about regarding
the performance of a portfolio.
They are cumulative return,
average daily return,
standard deviation of daily return and
sharp ratio.
Cumulative return is just a measure of
how much the value of the portfolio has
gone up from the beginning to the end.
So to calculate that, we take the last
val, which is port-val of -1.
Which is this one divided by
the beginning and subtract 1.
Average daily return is just
the average of these numbers, so
we just take the mean.
Very simple.
And standard deviation of daily return,
again simple.
Just use the standard deviation
function right there.
Now sharpe ratio is a little bit
more complex than these other ones.
So we're going to spend a little bit
more time diving into sharpe ratio.